POLICE OFFICER.
THE SUSPECT WAS KILLED TODAY IN
TENNESSEE.
TONIGHT THE FUTURE OF
SELF-DRIVING CARS.
WOULD YOU GET INTO ONE.
MANY BELIEVE THEY ARE COMING AND
SOON.
THERE ARE DEFINITELY SAFETY
ISSUES THAT COULD PUT ON THE
BRAKES.
BRIAN REPORTS TONIGHT FROM
PITTSBURGH.
>> WHETHER IT'S PICKING UP
CUSTOMERS IN LAS VEGAS OR
DELIVERING A PIZZA IN MICHIGAN
OR MIAMI, DRIVERLESS VEHICLES
ARE BE TESTED EVERYWHERE.
ENGINEERS PARTNERED WITH GENERAL
MOTORS.
>> WE HAVE RADAR BEHIND THE
LOGO.
>> THIS 2011 CADILLAC DRIVES BUT
WITH A HUMAN TEST DRIVER ON
BOARD.
THE ULTIMATE GOAL IS TO CREATE
THE WORLD'S FIRST VEHICLE THAT
DRIVES ITSELF ANYWHERE IN ANY
CONDITIONS.
>> IT WILL TAKE AT LEAST 8 TO 10
YEARS BEFORE WE REACH THIS.
>> THE RACE TO BE FIRST IS UNDER
WAY.
GENERAL MOTORS WILL LAUNCH
SELF-DRIVING VEHICLES IN U.S.
CITIES.
OTHER DRIVERLESS CARS HAVE
DRIVEN 5 MILLION MILES.
IT WILL LAUNCH A RIDE SHARING
SERVICE THIS YEAR.
THERE ARE NEW CONCERNS ABOUT
SAFETY.
UBER SUSPENDED CAR TESTING AFTER
A SELF-DRIVING CARS HIT AND
KILLED A WOMAN.
THE COMPANY IS ACCUSED OF
COMPROMISING SAFETY TO CATCH UP
WITH COMPETITION.
AN ACCUSATION IT DENYS.
>> MAYBE NOW IS THE TIME TO
THINK ABOUT HOW UBER WORKS IN
THE CITY.
>> MICHAEL LAMB IS PITTSBURGH'S
CITY CONTROLLER.
HIS CITY WELCOMED UBER UNDER THE
HANDSHAKE PERHAPS OF A
PARTNERSHIP WHICH HE SAID IS ONE
SIDED.
>> WE OPENED THE CITY TO THEM.
ALLOWED THEM TO TEST THEIR
VEHICLES HERE.
THEY ARE COLLECTING DATA.
>> SHOULDN'T THE CITY BENEFIT?
>> 2 STATES ENACTED VEHICLE
LEGISLATION SO FAR AS GOVERNMENT
TRIES TO CATCH UP WITH AN
INDUSTRY IN THE FAST LANE.
INCLEMENT WEATHER IS A BIG
HURLED FOR THESE VEHICLE.
HEAVY RAIN MAKES IT DIFFICULT
FOR THE CARS TO PICK UP OBJECTS.